was geht hier sah max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video ich spiele
heute zusammen mit luca eine challenge
wie auch immer man möchte ich mir selbst
ausgedacht habe und zwar haben wir etwas
aufgebaut
ihr seht hier unterschiedliche tassen
und gläser gleich wird in alle tassen
wasser gefüllt und in die gläser werden
die unterschiedlichsten unappetitlichen
flüssigkeiten bzw
nicht so ganz flüssigkeiten eingefügt
einmal haben wir hier maria pistor
arrabiata arrabiata ist scharf für die
nicht italiener und dann haben wir hier
kokoswasser finde ich persönlich absolut
eklig du kannst noch nicht getrunken
zu guter letzt zitronensaft sauer ist
kennt jeder das prinzip von spiels aber
man wird diesen ball und lässt ihn
einmal auf doch zum beziehungsweise
wirkt direkt und wenn er bald in ein
glas reinfeldt dann muss die flüssigkeit
die sich darin befindet getrunken werden
ja und so machen wir das jetzt erfüllen
als auch
so sollte wir fangen jetzt an alles ist
aufgebaut jeder zwei würfeln der jeweils
anderen aussagen legen wir los
was passt was möchte ich als erstes
schwarzer cut paste so sehen uns diese
marke nicht einer schädigung acht stimmt
das dürfen wir auch mit dem optischen
nein basta auch noch also einmal rasse
an der dachluke schon trinken als macher
und genießt es meine meine unfähigkeit
zu treffen sagt leider versagt direkt
einfach zusammen
jetzt gehe ich für die reise in der
schafe ist ich habe bis 50 hatte starb
man okay man diesen komischen bayern ich
muss jeden ball richtig schön
abschnitten oder konstante konstanten
wird ein schönes stück
christoph 45 33 halter
vor allem ein wasser zitrone leute die
gehen jetzt ein bisschen näher als ein
bisschen leichter wird als beim machen
alles richtig gemacht habe
dabei macht die hälfte viele leute ein
kräftiger schluck zitrone wohl auch oft
ich locker und unabhängig zu sein
wir haben jetzt ab sofort noch eine
kamera für die letzten beiden für zeigen
dass wasser viele wissen wahrscheinlich
wieder schmeckt so ich finde ich bin
kein scheiß ich denke ich nach kopf
gerade das erste mal probiert nicht ich
bin eh keiner was ist sinn und ein
großer rucksack
ich finds richtig erwischt er schmeckt
so ein bisschen die abgestandene milch
wir haben lustigen nach geschmack ist es
das ende von macht der musik bringen
über wir von einer der gewinner dann
einfach auf das wäre ich am meisten an
vettel verloren aber ich werde es mir
haben sie nehmen einen schluck von dem
wunderbaren hat die abnehmbaren eines
sprachlich noch mit kokosnuss vermischt
das ist nicht die welt verändert müssen
das wird für uns definitiv müsse alle
kräfte habe für mich etwas niedriger
sein können zu einem klick den blue
chips als reine damen und herren dass
ihr es jetzt kokosmilch
mit diesem komischen schaffen und noch
etwas macht mit diesem zitronenwasser so
leute hier ist das wunderbar gemisch
zitronensaft kokoswasser und wer jetzt
zweieinhalb jahre nach vorn jetzt ein
kräftiges gewicht gefallen hat
schmeckt wirklich nach wird sich
wirklich nach kotze also ich wurde das
rohr werdet euch gefallen hat zeigt max
mit einer bewertung der trinkwasser in
kommentare lieblingsfach durchs dorf
leute richtig widerlich
ich war richtig heiß ich habe einen ganz
gefallen schauen wir bei lukas kanal
vorbei des ganzen die beschreibung und
dann war es von heute macht gut und bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss